Brenda and Adagio el faro are struggling
to hold back tears they're opening up
for the first time about the
disappearance of their eldest son owed a
CEO who was kidnapped in 2015 and never
heard from again if you ask what the
hardest part is I think it's living day
to day living day to day is like being
alive in death since the disappearance
of their son the couple say their lives
have been turned upside down
I lost everything
it's too difficult I lost my job
mmm it hurts too much
remember this cases like these number in
the tens of thousands across much of
Mexico mental health experts say the
increasing violence nationwide is
creating long-term negative impacts on
the lives of those affected in
situations only exist in Valencia in
situations where violence is present
health conditions are tripled 22% of the
population facing violence are currently
affected by mental health conditions
we're talking about depression anxiety
and in extreme conditions
schizophrenia suicide and addiction for
some the trauma of losing a loved one to
violence can consume their lives and in
Mexico forced disappearances have become
so common that forensics workshops are
now taught to family members who refuse
to give up the search for the
disappeared along with homicides
kidnappings extortion and attacks
against women have continued to grow
beyond the control of Mexican
authorities the statistics associated
with escalating violence in Mexico means
that public health services are often
overwhelmed and in many cases survivors
are left to help each other to overcome
the emotional trauma Mexico is expected
to close out 2019 as the most violent
year on record
this means more families will share the
same pain as Fernanda and Odyssey unfair
Oh Manuel Arevalo al Jazeera Mexico City